you
all right team white Fisher random where
do we go hmm time to think this one
through he's not I don't need to move
him I just need to move the pond and
he's already happy he's already happy
happy happy
duck dynasty style right what about f4
he's opened the rook is happy a little
bit everybody's everybody's happy okay
what are my other considerations is it
this beautiful right I'm playing white
my clock is not ticking and I get to
just brainstorm this initial position
all right let's maybe he's garbage right
here let's start with this one
Oh actually I one of the first things I
do is identify what's unprotected this
is unprotected so this is another reason
to start out with this Queen takes a
seven on move - you can't do that in
regular chess so I could grab him if I
want but you know what I'm gonna do not
grab him I think he's poisoned don't
grab those poison pawns now why is he
poison you might ask do you know how
difficult it is to answer why question
any Richard Fineman fans Queen takes a
seven Knight b6 rook a eight I mean I
can run away but I just I think I'm
greatly inconvenienced so I don't want
to be inconvenienced well hang on yeah
let's go here for a brief second I
thought about this but then maybe black
can do similar with f5 striking at my
pawn and maybe well they that they'd
have the same issue if the Queen's
grabbing here but okay we could forget
about these pawn grabs do I have any
concern about the knight jumping in my
territory I don't think so I'm gonna do
this place a pawn in the center not just
a place upon in the center but I'm doing
this to potentially shut the door on the
bishop for if f5 then there comes a five
and he's kind of stuck
my night you know what I'm gonna keep
these guys sitting as is keep them right
there Knight c3 seems like a perfect
spot and this and where exactly do I
think I'm gonna Castle queenside might
not be a bad idea and I could do that as
soon as my night is on c3 let's get him
there well hang on maybe I consider this
I'm opening up this diagonal though hang
on for a second Knight c3 d4 or my
candidate moves well you know I still
want to be in a spot to meet f5 with e5
right now with this square being
controlled f f5 cannot be met with E 5
I'd be dropping upon or at least I think
so let me do this
I am weakening this square the knight
could hop to it my bishop is I have a
light square bishop that can control
this square but notice where he is he's
in the corner he's on the Kings side so
we view the board in sections quadrants
the ship that's kind of over here on the
Kings side light square bishop he's not
going to be too helpful so creating
light square weaknesses such as the c-4
square
I want to consider but I don't know I I
feel like I'd be able to kick him out or
at least challenge them with like 92 or
even Knight - III not quite sure what he
wants to do is an interesting position
these two diagonals should be coming out
out ok so he's hit now I think it's time
to move my pawn just a single step
because I may still want to Castle
kingside even though I've moved these
puns that was like a kingside fianchetto
I really do I really would have to clear
out these 3 pieces I think what's more
likely is
we inside castle so I need only move my
knight to somewhere this guy dropped my
King on my rook and then he ends up here
okay just under three minutes for my
opponent bad but slow my opponent so I
guess they're really trying to get this
move in and I might be able to clog up
this position I'm really considering
this since they kind of shut the door on
their bishop maybe I could do this grab
some space clamp down on this square
maybe or how about this let's consider
this one with tempo but maybe I'm
kicking the bishop to a spot that's a
little bit annoying I'm gonna go here
maybe on my next turn I'll consider this
so that I don't I now don't have to
worry about a counter attacking Bishop
to b5 move about even on time queenside
castle seems like the right way to go
all right so we are having this I don't
want to capture
I think capturing simply helps mobilize
rook and bishops so I'm just going to I
think I want to do this
grab some space do so with tempo and
well maybe I could even consider this
mmm I really might want to consider that
yeah this is starting to become a bit
more appealing or I look at it I realize
takes takes he's not gonna be a problem
but
what else can I do see if I don't do
this maybe this move comes and these
guys come right to life so you know what
I am hang on now I'd have something good
for that I was thinking for a second
about if takes takes there is Queen g5
but I have a convenient reply Bishop d2
counter-attack I'd you have to be
careful this pawn is kind of viewing it
right now is being unprotected so let me
get here the bishops trying to get on
this diagonal so I'm gonna try to get
there first I'm not trying but like I
was gonna say this pawn it's attacked
twice it's defended twice in my mind
it's unprotected so I'm looking at other
moves that could be attacking it again
Queen g5 was one of them maybe the only
one but something to look into
okay and now I don't
I really don't see a reason not well
yeah the Bishop's ready to play here let
me let me get castled my bishop could
use what was I gonna say my bishop could
go somewhere else I mean right now it's
just a one directional it's just
focusing on this one
diagonal here he starts to form an X
Bishop to f3 g4 my candidate moves I'm
gonna go with g4
you take towards the center I take
towards the center and I have a strong
grip right here I have what you can say
I have a space advantage in the center
and on the Queen side
well actually the whole board this
structure right here is really claiming
space at in every which way it's very
difficult to work around work around
that let me take and get my Queen a bit
more active hitting the knight right now
as a follow up I just want to make sure
I don't have to worry about this let's
get him here if this file opens up I
could eventually be gaining a tempo on
the Queen now that she's on h7 there is
Knight c4 still but I don't see a move
that's tied in well with this this would
be incredibly weakening if you're gonna
support it with the b5 it's not being
supported he's just gone there should be
five is not there take rook h1 now that
this file is completely open take
towards the center my king still has an
unopened diagonal but I'm not seeing
anything that could really be harmful to
me right now in fact with this base
advantage on the Kings side well just
this extra piece really I'm gonna try to
put it to use there's really not a need
to even come over here I'm looking to
pinpoint b7 a knight on this edge of the
board is very very annoying if he's ever
kicked he just enters an I'm an even
more annoying square so I'm threatening
mate on b7 that's it
hunt the King down no time no position
at this point checkmate is the threat at
that point alright he's down on time
good game let's go back and like before
let me bring up this game like so so we
get to see the a bigger board yeah I
think these are poison pawns I've this
is not the first time that I've seen
this come about when playing Fischer
random but grabbing here these moves
like Knight b6 with rook e8 already
looking to trap the Queen I think it's
strictly a pawn grab that you shouldn't
go for I don't even know you for you are
winning upon it may turn out that black
it's the pawn back and does so with a
rook who's you know there's there's not
going to be a worry of a rook getting
trapped on a 2 unless some piece could
like camp out on a 3 but it's just not
happening with the Queen however it's a
bit scary so neither of us would bite
well I didn't I didn't bite with
grabbing a7 and I wonder if there's
actually even a better start right here
instead of this you could always just do
this move f5 keep things and just just
play symmetrical for at least right now
it's not a bad move
definitely not a bad move controls a
center square if he's ever capturing
your rook comes to life that's kind of
my idea when I do this pawn move in
front of my rook you have this but I end
up starting to get a really good
Center I wonder if it already becomes
very important you know
like instead of moving your night well
maybe maybe there is some concern about
me actually grabbing this but I don't
think it's even still there takes not
here I'm looking to trap the Queen and
then this you get it back so maybe maybe
you could go forward with a move you did
play but one will sooner you played
Knight b6 and then d6 but I wonder about
playing d6 right now and then well maybe
maybe even f5 right now still at 5 yeah
that way he is he's never really gonna
get shut out of the game if I'm to shut
the bishop out of the game if you have
the pawn on f5 if I'm ever gonna have
thoughts of shutting the bishop down
with my pawn structure I'd end up having
to play d3 d4 you could take I could
take and then finally I can do this but
it's I don't even I don't even know if
that would be a good thing to shoot for
but it definitely takes more work I'm
not you're not having to deal with a
group of three ponds d4e for f4 as was
the case in the game and so maybe this
f5 move would just be a good one right
now just just like I did I'll eventually
have to do similar you play g6 Island up
having to do something my jeep on but I
think he needed to get working what was
what did he end up doing in the game he
ended up playing to f6 and these are
well now that I have this Center it
gains in strength because there's now
the possibility for that that strong
center to advance now with tempo grab
some space there's there's not really a
way that you could undermine it there's
if there's a way to undermine a center
you really need to do so in a timely
fashion so if I have if I if I have a
center like this and I'm given time to
reinforce it with my pieces
there's not really going to be
compensation you really need to strike
while the iron's hot is what I'm getting
at so I have a center you really need to
strike at it really soon maybe it's
already starting to be a little bit too
late before I even consider something
like this maybe maybe it's already quite
critical from a strategical standpoint
you need to need to play that pawn up to
f5 some Fischer random position that can
certainly be more critical than others
and I think this are these started to
become quite critical very early on I
don't know my my best suggestions are
the ones that are coming early on in
this configuration this arrangement we
ended up working with so I know you
ended up dropping a piece and then I
grabbed on b7 it's the typical domino
effect lose want one one piece files the
others are easy to follow thereafter and
it's really it's really getting all the
way back to playing f5 I'm pretty sure
before I'm even at this point right here
before I'm even at this point instead of
the knight move f5 I mean well I know
we're only up move two but yeah okay I'm
not sure what else to really say okay
good game
you